the numbers on luis castillo
he has completed six innings just once
in his eight starts
he comes off his shortest outing since
opening day he failed to go four
eight runs ten hits in three and two
thirds many elements 3-2
swing and a foul tip caught cleaned by
tucker barnhart strike three
we saw the fastball fastball up in the
zone and there's the changeup
change-up works win at fastball location
is good
rough up there hitting 228 five homers
13 rbis here
and a swing and a miss he struck him out
another slider down and away
rough and underwater swing and back to
back strikeouts for luis castillo
swinging a miss out in front luis
castillo overwhelmingly dominant
for the san francisco giants is anthony
d schlafani
31 year old right hander returns to
great america ballpark for the first
time since joining the giants
what a one-two the reds have lark winker
at the plate castellano
on deck first and second in the national
league and hitting
and that one is rocketed deep right
center field healthy retreat and it
carries it's gone
a wink and a bomb
and the reds get their first first
inning run
in a while to back up luis castillo it's
one to nothing
well jesse winker at the top of the
lineup has just been amazing this year
his aggressiveness is just look at the
balance stand behind that baseball
extending those arms
on it first two outs alex dickerson at
the plate
castillo turns it loose and there's a
line drive headed to the right center
field gap that's going to get down and
go to the wall
flores headed for third he's getting the
wave by ron wotis and now the stop sign
goes up right as he got to third base
it'll be a double for
alex dickerson boy flores was just not
running he should have scored easily on
that and he was jogging between
second and third and lotus was
raped waving him home aggressively
and then just put up the stop sign
because flores couldn't run he may have
to come out of this game
yeah he's out of the game well that's
not good well
as we get a runner here it's mauricio
dubon is going to run
the base is loaded diesel funny has hit
a grand slam
in this stadium 1-2 swinging a miss he
struck him out
two on and no down and here is tucker
barnhart
swinging a miss struck him out breaking
ball down and in
and that is the second strikeout for
diesel
funny now he'll deal with alex blandino
with luis castillo waiting
on deck so that makes this a very big at
bat
good comeback fastball execution by d
stefani he starts it off the plate it
was a two-seamer came back to the
outside corner
now luis castillo two on and two out
got him with 96. nice job by disco funny
as he strikes out the side and mike
talkman struck out first time up mired
in a three for 24 slide
these guys and see how they interact
with each other
ben the knee mike talkman luis
castillo's dominance continues
his sixth strikeout of the day shift is
on daryn ruff is struck out
swinging a miss a season high tying
seven strikeouts and it's only the third
inning
two out walk now evan longoria two two
swing and a miss a season high
eight strikeouts through three dominant
endings
and the giants are in business here in
the fourth inning with runners at the
corners and
nobody out alex dickerson doubled first
time up against castillo
that ball down the right field line deep
way back there
goodbye a three-rod homer for alex
dickerson and the giants
jump ahead 3-1 well looks like alex
dickerson may be heating up
gets a change up up out over the plate
eyes big right on the ball stays right
on it
barrels it hits it out to right field
big swing at the back by alex dickerson
after coming off the il
the 2-2 pitch strike three called got
him looking
down on strikes d funny and that's nine
strikeouts for
luis castillo tonight back to the top of
the order and mike talkman
check swing did he go yes 10 strikeouts
for luis castillo
and the giants have runners in second
and third with nobody out and here's
evan longoria
he's one of the elite superstars
swinging a miss
and luis castillo 11 strikeouts
a comeback dave for one of the reds aces
brandon crawford is struck out
payoff grounded to blandino runner
breaks throw to the plate it's there the
tag dropped
he's out blandino the dime is rough dead
to rights at the dish
and a big second out in the inning well
the joy of work with alex blandino and
tyler stevenson in first base coming
into play
the 1-1 pitch breaking ball popped him
up
off first foul ground over to have a
look blandino near the reds dugout he
makes the catch at the rail and
castillo works out of the second and
third
nobody out jam giants are held scoreless
in the fifth
well with the right-hander karen ruff
coming to the point the reds go to the
bullpen and bring on right-hander heath
hembree looking for at least one batter
to get out with runners aboard here
in the sixth inning for the giant and
breeze delivery
runners go take it for called strike
three
rough down on strikes a dirty dozen k's
for reds pitching tonight hunter pitches
the most that decline has
thrown on the year and that happened
against colorado back in april
popped up casalli on the run along with
ruff ruff oh what a play
just before he was about to be rudely
introduced to that
dugout screen went into a slide and made
the catch
a brandon belt caliber play there
crawford
was struck out singled and hit into a
fielder's choice so here's one for three
crawford hits one very high
very deep very fair out of here
big swing of the bat add-on run here
late in the game
crawford with his 10th home run of the
year see right here
leaves it up in the zone crawford
doesn't miss it
just gets the barrel of the ball four
runs in the game
all on home runs of this series that's
only the second hit
this year allowed by heath hembree
by the way of all the starters
he had a that shutout earlier in the
season
i get stefani who has had the giants
only complete game
he threw a hundred pitches in that game
and that's the only other time in his
nine starts that he has reached 100
pitches thrown
and here's the pitch to winker he swings
and that's a line drive right to
dubai's second he grabs it on a hop and
throws him out at first and
just like that the inning is over that
ball was hit hard
but right at him the new pitcher is zach
lately
here is nick castellanos leading things
off with the reds trailing by
three 4-1 in the eighth and that is
hammer
crush to left center castaianos
it his team-leading 11th home run
crown mike duckman has just moved from
center field to left so he got a front
row seat to watch that sail over his
head
[Applause]
suarez and crawford on the backhand
and he throws him out unbelievable
oh and this ballpark you know you're
going to see some home runs but you need
some good
defensive plays as well giants with a 42
lead as we go to the bottom of the ninth
and jake mcgee
is the new pitcher here's stevenson
comes back with a fastball and a pop-up
dan ruff doing the pop-up dance and he
makes the catch
and that's the ball game never a doubt
so in a game that was odd odd in the
sense where the giants struck out
120 times today and they won the ball
game